We want to learn to compute shortest path and Again, it could be done using matrix multiplication over a tropical semi-rig. This is something you could use on a date And you are the weakest link goodbye Right, let's start with the headlines I Swear now Right, let's start with the headlines. I swear now. If you're not with someone your age, you'll regret it. Maybe not today, maybe not tomorrow, but soon. And for the rest of your life. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 222 recorded on February 17th, 2025.
我们想要学习计算最短路径，同样，这可以通过在热带半环上进行矩阵乘法来完成。这东西你可以在约会时用上。你是最弱的一环，再见。好了，让我们从头条新闻开始。我现在发誓。好了，让我们从头条新闻开始。我现在发誓。如果你不和同龄人在一起，你会后悔的。也许不是今天，也许不是明天，但很快。而且会伴随你的余生。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 222 期，录制于 2025 年 2 月 17 日。
My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we chat with Tristan Brindle in part one of this four or five part conversation. In today's episode, we chat about some graph algorithm resources, the book from mathematics to generic programming, the mathematicians Euler and Galois, and some of our current favorite TV shows and movies and more. I had a couple of thoughts on your graph algorithms discussion with Bryce. What is that? This is a book that if you like graph algorithms you should read. Yeah this is Mazes for Programmers by Giamis book and that does sound pretty cool. It covers all that because you know constructing minimum spanning
我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起，我们与 Tristan Brindle 进行了这场四到五部分对话的第一部分。在今天的节目中，我们聊了一些图算法资源、《从数学到泛型编程》这本书、数学家欧拉和伽罗瓦，以及我们目前最喜欢的一些电视节目和电影等等。我对你和 Bryce 关于图算法的讨论有一些想法。那是什么？这是一本如果你喜欢图算法就应该读的书。是的，这是 Giamis 写的《程序员的迷宫》，听起来确实很酷。它涵盖了所有这些内容，因为你知道，构建最小生成
trees is the same problem as making mazes. If you think about like a grid of cells you want to construct a minimum spanning tree across those cells that is a maze. And there are various ways to do that. There are like I don't know 20 different algorithms in here. Crimson Pruskals just what they say Prims and Kr crusticles, just scratch the surface. There's all kinds of interesting algorithms. One of the interesting ones is called Ella's. And Ella's algorithm is interesting because each successive row of the maze is constructed from the previous row only, which means that...
树和制作迷宫是同一个问题。如果你想象一个单元格网格，想要在这些单元格中构建一棵最小生成树，那就是一个迷宫。实现这一点有多种方法。这里面大概有 20 种不同的算法。Prim 和 Kruskal 算法只是触及了皮毛。还有各种有趣的算法。其中一个有趣的算法叫 Ella 算法。Ella 算法很有趣，因为迷宫的每一行都是仅根据前一行构建的，这意味着……
This is the one you showed in a C++ Now talk, yeah? Yeah, which means that it's an iterative process. You can iterate until you've had enough constructing each next row from the previous one for a given width of maze, obviously. But that's a really good book. And the other thing I wanted to draw your attention to for your consideration is this blog post from a while ago. It's called A Very General Method of Computing Shortest Paths. And it covers an algorithm, the Gauss-Jordan-Floyd-Warshall-Cleanie algorithm. That's four hyphens for those of you that didn't pick up. I did complain about the hyphenation of these, you know, specific algorithms.
这就是你在 C++ Now 大会上展示的那个，对吧？是的，这意味着它是一个迭代过程。你可以一直迭代，直到你构建完每一行，当然是针对给定宽度的迷宫。但那真是一本好书。我想提请你注意的另一件事是前段时间的这篇博文。它叫《一种计算最短路径的非常通用的方法》。它涵盖了一种算法，即 Gauss-Jordan-Floyd-Warshall-Kleene 算法。对于那些没听出来的人，那是四个连字符。我确实抱怨过这些特定算法的连字符用法。
That's four hyphens, five names in this algorithm. Well, because, I mean, that algorithm is, it's an amalgamation of other algorithms, right? But it's a method of computing transitive closures with using a mathematical structure called the tropical star semi-ring, which you may have heard of. So this is crazy we got a possible for a second so i'm not exactly sure where i start the edit of part one of this probably three parts you know in part conversation but we do have a guest with us tristan who i think is our second most frequent guess behind Sean parent and i think Ben I don't know how we count you anymore because you've been upgraded
那是四个连字符，这个算法里有五个名字。嗯，因为，我的意思是，那个算法是其他算法的融合，对吧？但它是一种使用名为“热带星半环”的数学结构来计算传递闭包的方法，你可能听说过。这太疯狂了，我们先暂停一下，我不确定我该从哪里开始剪辑这部分，这可能是三部分对话中的第一部分，但我们确实有一位嘉宾 Tristan，我认为他是继 Sean Parent 之后我们第二频繁的嘉宾，而且 Ben，我不知道该怎么算你了，因为你已经升级了。
So if Ben's now like an official co-host does that mean I move up in the yeah, I think After this you might already be in second because all of his co-host episodes don't count towards his guest count so I think you might be we'll just call you the second most frequent and They don't count. So I think you might be, we'll just call you the second most frequent. And we're gonna be talking about a bunch of stuff over the next couple slices of this conversation. But so we're gonna start off, I guess,
所以如果 Ben 现在是正式的联合主持人，那是不是意味着我的排名上升了？是的，我想在这一期之后，你可能已经是第二名了，因为他所有的联合主持集数都不计入他的嘉宾次数，所以我认为你可能是……我们直接叫你第二频繁的嘉宾吧。而且他们不算数。所以我认为你可能是……我们直接叫你第二频繁的嘉宾吧。在接下来的对话中，我们将讨论很多事情。但我们先从……我想，
on follow ups to the graph algorithms conversation. It is crazy. Like the, what do you call it? Like the conflagration. Is that the correct word when you've got like ideas that pop up? A conflagration is a big fire, if that's what you meant.
关于图算法对话的后续讨论开始。这太疯狂了。就像，你管它叫什么？就像“大火”（conflagration）。当你有一些想法突然冒出来时，这是正确的词吗？Conflagration 是指大火，如果你是这个意思的话。
Okay. It's definitely not conflagration is a big fire if that's what you meant. Okay, it's definitely not conflagration It might be conflation, but I'm pretty sure that's that's when you confuse things or put them in the same idea But you just said tropical semi ring and I literally yesterday was working through One of the exercises from the spoils of Egyptians journey one from Stepanov's lecture series that corresponds to FM to GP from Mathematics to Generic Programming. And at one point he assigns the exercise of determining shortest path using a tropical semi-ring
好吧。绝对不是，Conflagration 是指大火，如果你是这个意思的话。好吧，绝对不是 Conflagration。可能是“混淆”（conflation），但我很确定那是当你把事情搞混或把它们归为同一个概念时。但你刚才说了热带半环，我昨天正好在做 Stepanov 讲座系列中《从数学到泛型编程》对应的《埃及人的战利品》练习题之一。在某个点上，他布置了使用热带半环确定最短路径的练习，
with matrix exponentiation. And then I have to implore the listener, if you have not listened to this lecture series, it is like 50% C++ and math and proofs. The other 50% is just listening to one of the world's most passionate people talk about history and mathematics and like stories of Pythagoras and Thales of Miletus and it is just like, half of these lectures you can literally watch as like a form of entertainment and and when he mentions the Tropical semi-ring he says and of course this is obviously amazing date material something you have to bring up on your next date and you say I'm implementing shortest path with the tropical semi-ring and my matrix multiplication mathematicians sometimes love to introduce really hot concepts.
并结合矩阵幂运算。我不得不恳求听众，如果你还没有听过这个讲座系列，它大约 50% 是 C++、数学和证明。另外 50% 只是听世界上最热情的人之一谈论历史、数学，以及像毕达哥拉斯和米利都的泰勒斯的故事，这简直就像，这些讲座中有一半你完全可以当作一种娱乐来看。当他提到热带半环时，他说，当然，这显然是绝佳的约会素材，是你下次约会时必须提起的，你说：“我正在用热带半环和矩阵乘法实现最短路径。”数学家有时喜欢引入非常热门的概念。
So recently they introduced the notion of a tropical semi-ring. It comes from Brazil. It's indeed, I mean, it was sort of, it existed in computer science by the way for decades and they paid no attention and then a Brazilian mathematician started using this thing for algebraic geometry and obviously in a computer science application is just nobody cares. The moment they start applying it to algebraic geometry it became very cool and they they named, since he
所以最近他们引入了热带半环的概念。它来自巴西。确实，我的意思是，它在计算机科学中存在了几十年，但没人注意，然后一位巴西数学家开始在代数几何中使用这个东西，显然在计算机科学应用中没人关心。当他们开始将其应用于代数几何时，它变得非常酷，他们命名了它，因为他
was from Brazil, they invented this concept of a tropical semi-ring. So you should feel really samba or whatever they do there. We want to learn to compute shortest path. And again, it could be done using matrix multiplication over a tropical semi-rig. This is something you could use on a date. And then, you know, I end up doing this in APL, which is like it has an inner product primitive, which you can just replace each binary operation and it works on matrices and it's like a one liner. Anyways, back to you.
来自巴西，他们发明了热带半环这个概念。所以你应该感受到桑巴舞或者他们在那里做的任何事情。我们想要学习计算最短路径。同样，这可以通过在热带半环上进行矩阵乘法来完成。这东西你可以在约会时用上。然后，你知道，我最终用 APL 做了这个，它有一个内积原语，你可以直接替换每个二元运算，它就能在矩阵上工作，就像一行代码一样。总之，回到你这里。
Sorry, is this the A9 lecture series? Yes. Yes. Have you seen them, is this the A9 lecture series? Yes, yes. Have you seen them Tristan? I know you know of them. I have, I know. It's the short version. I've watched bits here and there, but no, I've not sat down and watched the whole thing. But I always feel like I should. So... I mean, it's a hundred hours of material easily because between... There's Efficient Programming with Components is one of the series. The one Connor's talking about is the sports of the Egyptian... It's the algorithmic journeys, right?
抱歉，这是 A9 讲座系列吗？是的。是的。你看过吗，Tristan？我知道你知道它们。我看过，我知道。这是简短的版本。我看过一些片段，但我没有坐下来看完整个系列。但我总觉得我应该看。所以……我的意思是，这很容易就有 100 小时的内容，因为在……《使用组件的高效编程》是系列之一。Connor 谈论的是《埃及人的战利品》……是《算法之旅》，对吧？
Algorithmic journeys. Yeah, four algorithmic journeys and it's three journeys. The first one is the spoils of Egyptians and we haven't gotten to number two and number three. One of them is the successils of Egyptians and we haven't gotten to number two and number three. Like one of them is the successors of piano. I don't think that one is only a portion of the like the ones you're mentioning or other series, but I think this one grand total is probably going to be less than 30 or 40 hours. So it's I mean, that sounds like a lot, but if you're putting them on a two point time speed, because a lot of them is just like story time was stepping off. Like it's just it's just like, yeah, you'll feel I have to now tell you the story of Galois
《算法之旅》。是的，四次算法之旅，其实是三次旅程。第一个是《埃及人的战利品》，我们还没讲到第二和第三个。其中一个是《皮亚诺的继承者》。我不认为那是全部，只是你提到的部分或其他系列，但我认为这个总共可能不到 30 或 40 小时。所以我的意思是，这听起来很多，但如果你以 2 倍速播放，因为其中很多只是 Stepanov 的讲故事时间……就像是，是的，你现在会觉得我必须告诉你伽罗瓦的故事。
You know the most romantic of the mathematicians and he's always commenting this mathematician had a sword this mathematician didn't have a sword And it's a he's it is and he does it all off the cuff like this guy's Capacity for memorizing like the history of stuff. It's unbelievable back to you though. Galois died in a duel. That's right He yeah, yeah 21 years old and he of stuff. It's unbelievable. Back to you though. Galois died in a duel though, right? That's right. He uh... Yeah. Famously... Like 21 years old and he like wrote down the entirety of group theory like the night before because he thought he was going to die in the duel, which he did.
你知道他是数学家中最浪漫的一位，他总是评论说这个数学家有剑，那个数学家没有剑。而且他是即兴发挥的，这家伙对历史的记忆能力简直令人难以置信。不过回到你这里。伽罗瓦死于决斗。没错，他……是的，21 岁，他……回到你这里。伽罗瓦死于决斗，对吧？没错。他……是的……很有名……21 岁，他就像在决斗前夜写下了整个群论，因为他以为自己会死在决斗中，结果确实如此。
That is the story, yes. That's the famous story. But Stepanov does the same thing with programming languages as well. Not only is he a great mathematical historian, he's also a historian of our field, of the field of programming. So he talks about, in some of the other lecture series, he talks about the history of Fortran and Lisp and languages from the 60s, I guess we would say. Which I think more people should be aware of, you know, because we think that lots of things do get discovered in computer science still, but a lot of what we use day to day in computer science was already known by sort of 1975.
这就是那个故事，没错。那是著名的故事。但 Stepanov 在编程语言方面也做了同样的事情。他不仅是一位伟大的数学历史学家，也是我们这个领域——编程领域——的历史学家。所以他在其他一些讲座系列中谈到了 Fortran 和 Lisp 的历史，以及 60 年代的语言，我想我们可以这么说。我认为更多人应该意识到这一点，你知道，因为我们认为计算机科学中仍然有很多东西被发现，但我们日常在计算机科学中使用的大部分内容在 1975 年左右就已经为人所知了。
And our field is young enough that people can of 1975. And I feel is young enough that people can easily study the history. And it really helps to put things in context, I find. Yeah, he his anecdotes and I just can't even like I feel like there's someone should go and like edit out the math and C++ stuff and just stitch together the history parts as as just like a podcast because it is his anecdotes are... He's almost like part comedian because I find myself laughing when he's like, you know, the three rules of namings and of course, you know, I made the mistake myself and it's a tragedy because, you know, Vector, I violated rule number three and, you know, sometimes
而且我们的领域还很年轻，人们可以很容易地研究历史。我发现这真的有助于把事情放在背景中。是的，他的轶事，我甚至觉得应该有人去把数学和 C++ 的部分剪掉，只把历史部分缝合在一起，就像一个播客一样，因为他的轶事……他几乎像个喜剧演员，因为我发现当他说到“命名的三条规则”时，我会笑，当然，我自己也犯过错误，这真是一场悲剧，因为，你知道，Vector，我违反了第三条规则，而且，你知道，有时
mistakes they last a long time. And of course, like all of us used to vector today. And yeah, he is one of the best storytellers, if not the best storyteller in terms of like his not his knowledge that he's reaching from his own kind of comedic. But like edutainment, like doesn't do its service. It is it is so good. They even the proof stuff, if you're not there for C++ or for the math stuff, it's worth just like going through that for like the stories that he tells. And he's like, oh, now I promised you a story about Euler and now I will finally tell it. And then like
错误会持续很长时间。当然，我们今天都在使用 Vector。是的，他是最棒的讲故事的人之一，如果不是最棒的话，就他的知识而言，他不是从他自己的那种喜剧中获取的。但就像寓教于乐，这个词不足以形容。它太棒了。即使是证明的部分，如果你不是为了 C++ 或数学内容而来，也值得为了他讲的故事去看。他会说，“哦，现在我答应给你们讲一个关于欧拉的故事，现在我终于要讲了。”然后就像
30 minutes later, it's like, all right, it's the end of the lecture. We'll get back to C++ in the next one. Yeah, it's fantastic. Anyways, I've totally derailed Ben's talking about what is it, four? We should say that lecture series for algorithmic journeys is the lecture series of really of the book from mathematics to generic programming. So yes that book some people view as a sort of sequel to elements of programming. I don't it's not really a sequel but it is another book by Stepanov after Elements of Programming. So yeah, I haven't actually mentioned, I think I did mention at one point in our conversation
30 分钟后，他说，“好了，讲座结束了。我们下一节课再回到 C++。”是的，太棒了。总之，我完全打断了 Ben 关于那个什么，四？我们应该说《算法之旅》讲座系列就是《从数学到泛型编程》这本书的讲座系列。所以是的，有些人把那本书看作是《编程要素》的续集。我不觉得它是续集，但它是 Stepanov 在《编程要素》之后写的另一本书。所以是的，我其实还没提到，我想我在我们之前的对话中提到过，
a while ago, Ben, that I was going to be starting a meetup working through this book, but it's been like a month since we actually started it. So I mean, tonight, which will be in the past when this comes out, is meeting number three. But at the beginning of the meetup, in watching the lecture, Stepanov says that there's kind of a corresponding text, but not really, and that's EOP. But EOP was published before the four algorithmic journeys was recorded, and for mathematics to generic programming was published afterwards. So at the time he was recording it, he didn't mention for mathematics to generic programming was published afterwards. So at the time he was recording it, he didn't mention for mathematics to generic programming,
Ben，我要开始一个聚会来研读这本书，但我们开始已经有一个月了。所以我的意思是，今晚——当这期节目发布时已经是过去式了——是第三次聚会。但在聚会开始时，在观看讲座时，Stepanov 说有一本对应的教材，但其实也不完全是，那就是 EOP。但 EOP 是在《四次算法之旅》录制之前出版的，而《从数学到泛型编程》是在之后出版的。所以在他录制的时候，他没有提到《从数学到泛型编程》，
but it is completely clear after having like looked at both sources that they like one to one not in the same order, but they one to one map to each other like the diagrams and his slides are like copy and paste it to the textbook. So yeah, it's I think it's a great idea to work through both together. And if you're listening to this feel free whatever I'll leave a link in the show notes. Although we're already partially way through the book but yeah, it is I feel bad leaving it and not having gotten to it for so long because it's been on my list of things to do since like 2018 or 19 or something and
但在看过两个来源后，完全清楚它们是一一对应的，虽然顺序不同，但它们是一一映射的，比如他幻灯片上的图表就像是直接复制粘贴到教科书里的。所以是的，我认为把两者结合起来研读是个好主意。如果你正在听这个，请随意，我会把链接放在节目说明里。虽然我们已经读了一部分了，但是的，我感到很抱歉，因为我离开它太久了，它从 2018 或 19 年左右就在我的待办事项清单上了，而且
Just for like not even the education educational value just for the entertainment value. It is worth like going to and And watching yeah yeah I plan on going through everything now that I can find it's it's probably the same thing like I feel very sad that Ken Iverson like passed away before the age of online YouTube videos and stuff because I feel like he would have probably been the same kind of character in terms of his passion for his topic yeah right anyways links in the show notes for everything we just mentioned. Back to what we were talking about before.
不仅仅是为了教育价值，单是为了娱乐价值，它也值得一看。是的，是的，我打算把所有东西都看一遍，既然我能找到的话。这可能是一样的，我感到非常难过，Ken Iverson 在在线 YouTube 视频时代之前就去世了，因为我觉得他可能也会是那种对自己的主题充满热情的人。是的，总之，所有我们提到的东西的链接都在节目说明里。回到我们之前谈论的话题。
I still don't know what a tropical sub ring is though. Ben, you want to describe it or should I describe it? Let's see. It's, so it's a ring or semi ring, right? So semi ring is another one of these mathematical structures, like a group, except it's adding on more stuff. So are you familiar with the ring? So maybe for the listeners, if you're not.
我还是不知道什么是热带半环。Ben，你想描述一下，还是我来描述？让我们看看。它是一个环或半环，对吧？所以半环是这些数学结构中的另一种，就像群一样，只是它增加了更多的东西。那么你熟悉环吗？所以也许对听众来说，如果你不熟悉的话。
I did study this stuff, but quite a long time ago. Think of multiply and plus, right? That's the canonical example. So you've got two operations. It's like a group with two operations, right? And you've got like an additive identity, multiplicative identity, yeah. Yeah.
我确实学过这些东西，但那是很久以前的事了。想想乘法和加法，对吧？那是典型的例子。所以你有两个运算。它就像一个有两个运算的群，对吧？而且你有加法单位元、乘法单位元，是的。是的。
So- I don't know the semi bit. I forget what makes a semi ring versus a full ring, but it's similar to what makes a semi group versus a group, I expect. Yeah. A tropical semi ring, I think is a ring that uses plus and min, is it?
所以……我不知道“半”的部分。我忘了是什么让它成为半环而不是全环，但我预计这类似于什么让它成为半群而不是群。是的。热带半环，我想是一个使用加法和……是吗？
As the operations. Correct, yeah. Yeah. It's called tropical, I think, because the mathematician who introduced it was Brazilian or working in Brazil and mathematicians just have the sense of humor where they say, oh, let's call it tropical. Something of that nature. So you can-
作为运算。没错，是的。是的。它被称为“热带”，我想是因为引入它的数学家是巴西人或在巴西工作，数学家们有一种幽默感，他们会说，“哦，让我们叫它热带。”类似性质的东西。所以你可以……
Plus and min. So if you think of min and plus, and you think of their application to a graph, maybe you can sort of intuit that plus is adding up the weights between nodes. And min is finding the minimum path length. And so this ring structure when applied to graphs weighted graphs or otherwise
加法和最小值。所以如果你想到最小值和加法，并想到它们在图上的应用，也许你可以直觉地感觉到加法是把节点之间的权重加起来。而最小值是找到最短路径长度。所以当这种环结构应用于图——加权图或其他图——时，
Allows you to compute shortest paths among among other things Transitive closures also come into it. I would have to take your word for that. That's not I can't intuit that It sounds like overwhelmingly complicated, especially given the fact that it's a tropical semi ring with matrix multiplication. And I was like, I put it off for a few days for the homework that I was doing. But then when I went to do it, literally in APL, an inner product is spelled plus dot for the inner product and then times. So your first operation is the multiplication and then plus is the second one.
允许你计算最短路径以及其他东西。传递闭包也包含在其中。我得相信你的话。那不是……我无法直觉地理解它。这听起来极其复杂，特别是考虑到它是一个带有矩阵乘法的热带半环。我做了几天的家庭作业，把它推迟了。但当我去做的时候，在 APL 中，内积实际上是写成“加点”作为内积，然后是乘法。所以你的第一个运算是乘法，然后加法是第二个。
Literally for doing a shortest path with a quote unquote tropical semi-ring, I don't know why I'm saying quote unquote, it just sounds very fancy. You replace the plus with a minimum glyph and you replace the times with a plus glyph and then that's it. And so you put a matrix, you put the same matrix on either side of that and then that's a single step of the calculation of shortest path. And then if you do that for n equal to the number of steps that you need to get from your starting point to your end point, in the matrix that is a representation of your
实际上，为了用所谓的“热带半环”做最短路径——我不知道为什么我要说“所谓”，它听起来很高级——你把加法替换为最小值符号，把乘法替换为加法符号，然后就可以了。然后你放一个矩阵，在两边放同一个矩阵，那就是计算最短路径的一步。然后如果你这样做 n 次，n 等于你从起点到终点所需的步数，在那个矩阵中，就是你
graph is the shortest path from that point to that point. It's incredibly simple in a language where you have a generic inner product where you can pass any two custom binary operations in. But yeah, it does sound rather fancy when he's explaining it. And then in the lectures, he doesn't actually give an example or anything. He just explains it in the abstract and is like, oh, and go do it for homework. It sounds like I've got some homework to do. Yeah. So you can do things like, you know, if you have an adjacency matrix. So I've done a few of these things to try them out. If you have an adjacency, just an unweighted graph, you have an adjacency
图的表示，就是从那点到那点的最短路径。在一个拥有通用内积的语言中，这简直太简单了，你可以传入任何两个自定义的二元运算。但是的，当他解释的时候，它确实听起来相当高级。而且在讲座中，他实际上没有给出一个例子或什么。他只是在抽象中解释它，然后说，“哦，去把它当作家庭作业做吧。”听起来我还有些家庭作业要做。是的。所以你可以做一些事情，比如，如果你有一个邻接矩阵。所以我试着做了其中的一些事情。如果你有一个邻接矩阵，只是一个无权图，你有一个邻接
matrix that is basically a square, you can represent as a square matrix of bits, right, which you can represent as just an integral type if your graph is small enough. Or like n integral types, right, because it's bits. You can compute, if you take that as a matrix and you raise it to the nth power, basically it computes the transitive closure, where n is enough, basically until you stop, until it stops changing, kind of, right? Because at that point, you've computed the transitive closure of the graph.
矩阵，基本上是一个正方形，你可以把它表示为一个位正方形矩阵，对吧？如果你的图足够小，你可以把它表示为一个整数类型。或者像 n 个整数类型，对吧？因为它是位。你可以计算，如果你把它作为一个矩阵，并把它提高到 n 次方，基本上它就计算了传递闭包，其中 n 足够大，基本上直到它停止，直到它不再改变，对吧？因为在那一点上，你已经计算了图的传递闭包。
You can then, there are various things you can do. I think you can use that to extract a topological sort of the nodes, among other things. And you know, when we say a graph, also this link I put in the chat, you know, a graph is very general. A graph, for example, this can be applied to regular expressions, right? The cleanly star in the regular expression is the same thing as transitive closure. The idea of transitive closure.
然后你可以做各种事情。我想你可以用它来提取节点的拓扑排序，等等。而且你知道，当我们说图时，我放在聊天里的这个链接，你知道，图是非常通用的。例如，图可以应用于正则表达式，对吧？正则表达式中的 Kleene 星号就是传递闭包。传递闭包的概念。
Ben's just, you know, he operates in the clouds when us mere mortals operate down on earth. I will say as well, like one of the exercises in FM to GP is, you know, working up to calculating Fibonacci numbers in log n time using also matrix multiplication or exponentiation. And I follow the lectures. It makes sense. I nod my head along. And then once again, I go to APL, which has the matrix multiplication primitive. And so it's super straightforward.
Ben 只是，你知道，他在云端操作，而我们这些凡人在地球上操作。我还要说，FM to GP 中的练习之一是，你知道，通过矩阵乘法或幂运算在 log n 时间内计算斐波那契数。我跟着讲座走。这很有道理。我跟着点头。然后再一次，我转向 APL，它有矩阵乘法原语。所以它超级直接。
You build up this two by two matrix, put it to the nth power, and there's a kind of log n calculation where if it's even, you divide by two. If it's odd, you minus one. I implemented it. Do I fully understand, like at an intuitive level, how you get, you know, log n? Like I get it. We're splitting, dividing and conquer. I see it, but the math behind it, you know, I can say now that I can, you know, once again, if I'm ever on a date with my fiance, I'll say, I can do a Fibonacci calculations and log n time is pretty impressive But you know if if you actually asked me to explain the mathematics behind it or the intuition behind it I think it's very non intuitive. I mean stepanov said himself. He was like he didn't believe it when
你构建这个二乘二矩阵，把它提高到 n 次方，有一种 log n 的计算方法，如果是偶数，你就除以 2。如果是奇数，你就减 1。我实现了它。我是否完全理解，在直觉层面上，你是如何得到，你知道，log n 的？就像我明白了。我们在分治。我看到了，但背后的数学，你知道，我现在可以说，你知道，再一次，如果我以后和我的未婚妻约会，我会说，我可以在 log n 时间内进行斐波那契计算，这相当令人印象深刻。但你知道，如果你真的让我解释背后的数学或直觉，我觉得它非常不直观。我的意思是 Stepanov 自己也说了。他说他当时不相信
He came across you know this statement said oh you can do it in log n 10 He's like of course he can't you know it's a it's dependent on the previous two things like how could you possibly do that? In log n time? I'm not sure if you have an intuitive explanation, Ben. No, I don't think I do for that one. But yes, if you just play with, like you say, if you play with the matrices, you get the hang of it, get the idea of it. Like you said, it's fairly easy to understand how raising a matrix
他遇到了，你知道，这个陈述，说“哦，你可以在 log n 时间内完成。”他说，“当然不能，”你知道，它依赖于前两个东西，你怎么可能做到？在 log n 时间内？我不确定你是否有直观的解释，Ben。不，我不认为我有。但是的，如果你只是玩，就像你说的，如果你玩矩阵，你就会掌握它，理解它的想法。就像你说的，理解如何将矩阵
to the nth power can be done in log n steps rather than n, right? Because when you're raising to the power, if the power is even, you can halve it and do that multiplication after the divide and conquer. I just dropped in the chat, talking of enjoying history of mathematics, I dropped a link into a YouTube video in the chat, which is about Leonard Euler. It's called A Tribute to Euler by William Dunham. This is also, I think, a book. I think he's written a book on Euler.
提高到 n 次方可以在 log n 步内完成，而不是 n 步，对吧？因为当你提高幂时，如果幂是偶数，你可以把它减半，并在分治之后进行乘法。我刚才在聊天中发了一个链接，说到享受数学历史，我发了一个关于莱昂哈德·欧拉的 YouTube 视频链接，是 William Dunham 做的《向欧拉致敬》。这也是，我想，一本书。我想他写过一本关于欧拉的书。
But Euler is, Euler was amazing. You know, it may or may not surprise you to learn that all of Euler's work has not yet been published. Oh, wow. There are folks still going through his papers and publishing them and it's going to be a while before they'll get published. He has, I'm not sure if it's, if he's second to Gauss Gauss, but he might be first in a number of things that are named after him in mathematics.
但欧拉是，欧拉太神奇了。你知道，得知欧拉所有的作品还没有全部出版，可能会也可能不会让你感到惊讶。哦，哇。还有人在整理他的论文并出版，距离全部出版还需要一段时间。他有，我不确定他是否仅次于高斯，但他可能是数学中以他名字命名的东西数量最多的第一人。
How does Euler rank compared to von Neumann in terms of his, I don't know what you call it, like polymath status? Well, I couldn't say, but it's certainly true that Euler just blew the lid off multiple fields of mathematics. For example, perfect numbers and amicable numbers. So, perfect number is a number where the proper divisors sum to the number, like 6, 28, 496, I think. So, we know up until oiler
欧拉在“通才”地位方面与冯·诺依曼相比如何？嗯，我无法说，但欧拉确实在数学的多个领域掀起了风暴，这是肯定的。例如，完全数和亲和数。所以，完全数是一个数字，其真约数之和等于该数字本身，比如 6、28、496，我想。所以，我们知道直到欧拉
We had known a few of those were known to the ancients right and amicable numbers are numbers where? It's a pair of numbers where each numbers devises some to the other number wait say that again Amicable is when a pair of numbers. Oh some to each other So you know the sum of the A's divisors the divisors of A sum to B and the divisors of B sum to A. Okay. The proper divisors. So, 220 and 284 is the canonical example of a pair of amicable numbers. Euler, you know, so basically there were a handful of these perfect numbers and amicable
我们已经知道其中一些是古人所知的，对吧？亲和数是什么？这是一对数字，其中每个数字的约数之和等于另一个数字。等等，再说一遍。亲和数是当一对数字。哦，彼此之和。所以你知道，A 的约数之和，A 的约数之和等于 B，B 的约数之和等于 A。好的。真约数。所以，220 和 284 是亲和数对的典型例子。欧拉，你知道，所以基本上自古以来就有少数几个完全数和亲和
numbers known since antiquity. And I mean like two or three in perfect numbers and amicable numbers known since antiquity. And I mean like two or three in the case of amicable numbers. I forget things. Euler comes along, does a bit of work in this area and is like, oh here I've generated another two dozen. You know, the kind of impact he had on multiple areas of mathematics was like that. Anyway, it's a great video. We need some Apple TV or Netflix shows on, you know, the greats.
数为人所知。我的意思是，在亲和数的情况下只有两三个。我忘了事情。欧拉来了，在这个领域做了一些工作，然后说，“哦，看，我又生成了另外两打。”你知道，他对数学多个领域的影响就是那样。总之，这是一个很棒的视频。我们需要一些 Apple TV 或 Netflix 的节目，关于，你知道，那些伟大的数学家。
There's a TV show that just came out on, is it Apple? I don't know, called Prime Target. And it's it's based in Cambridge partly. So I'm not it might it may or may not be of interest to you. Did you do? Where did you go to school Tristan? I think I should know this. But is it Cambridge as well?
有一部刚出的电视剧，是在 Apple 上吗？我不知道，叫《Prime Target》。它部分以剑桥为背景。所以我不知道它是否会引起你的兴趣。你做过吗？Tristan，你在哪里上学？我想我应该知道这个。但也是剑桥吗？
Gasworks Polly? No, no, no. Where did you go to school, Tristan? I think I should know this, but is it Cambridge as well? Gasworks Poly? No, no, no. I, an ordinary university for me. I was an undergraduate at Southampton in the UK and I did a post-graduate Bath. Oh, Bath is a nice university. Bath is nice.
Gasworks Poly？不，不，不。Tristan，你在哪里上学？我想我应该知道这个，但也是剑桥吗？Gasworks Poly？不，不，不。我，对我来说是一所普通的大学。我是英国南安普顿大学的本科生，我在巴斯读了研究生。哦，巴斯是一所不错的大学。巴斯很好。
Yeah, yeah, it's a good place, yeah. And the city itself is amazing. The university is kind of 1960s modern thing at the top of the hill outside the Outside the city itself, but yeah bath is a fantastic place. You're gonna say something Connor Oh, no, I was gonna say I thought I got recommendations from from both of you of where to go When I was there, so maybe that's maybe I'm just miss Yeah, spent spent time in Cambridge. Okay.
是的，是的，是个好地方，是的。而且城市本身很棒。大学是那种位于城市外山顶上的 1960 年代现代建筑，但巴斯确实是个绝佳的地方。你要说什么，Connor？哦，不，我本来想说，我以为我从你们俩那里得到了去哪里的建议，所以也许我只是记错了。是的，在剑桥待过。好的。
But anyways, it's this TV show that it's about this, you know, genius math guy that is trying to find a prime finder and everybody's worried that, you know, supposedly all the NSA and all these organizations are killing off math people because- I think I've seen the trailer for that. It's on like Apple TV Yeah, yeah anyways, we need more shows like that with less killing and more just like the the true story of
但总之，这部电视剧是关于这个，你知道，天才数学家试图寻找素数查找器，每个人都担心，你知道，据称 NSA 和所有这些组织都在杀害数学家，因为……我想我见过那个预告片。它在 Apple TV 上。是的，是的，总之，我们需要更多那样的节目，少一点杀戮，多一点关于……的真实故事。
You know cuz you know, you could probably I don't know in this day and age There's a lot of tech people that I'm sure would be interested in math people that would be interested who knows though Not everybody's favorite show and they were a kid was Numbers like me. Talking of TV shows, I don't know maybe this isn't for, this won't be so interesting for the listeners maybe, but I had, before Christmas I was thinking you should do a Christmas special of this podcast. Right, so we're now going to have to wait until December again. But Connor, have you ever heard of a TV show called Countdown? A British TV show. Countdown?
你知道，因为你知道，你可能……我不知道，在这个时代，有很多科技人员，我相信会对数学家感兴趣，谁知道呢。不过并不是每个人小时候最喜欢的节目都是像我这样的《数字追凶》。说到电视节目，我不知道，也许这不适合，这对听众来说可能没那么有趣，但我，在圣诞节前，我在想你应该做一期这个播客的圣诞特辑。好吧，所以我们现在得等到十二月了。但 Connor，你听说过一个叫《Countdown》的电视节目吗？一个英国电视节目。《Countdown》？
I don't think so, although I have watched a bunch of, I know Ben, you've recommended me some quiz shows. I'm not sure it's the big quiz of the year, and there's other ones that are, some of them are funny, and some of them are actually like Mathlete, Olympiad. Countdown does not ring a bell though. Okay, so Countdown's like, it's been on TV since I think 1980 or 1982 or something. It's
我不这么认为，虽然我看过很多，我知道 Ben，你给我推荐过一些问答节目。我不确定是不是年度大问答，还有其他的，有些很有趣，有些实际上就像数学竞赛、奥林匹克竞赛。《Countdown》听起来不耳熟。好的，所以《Countdown》就像，它从 1980 年或 1982 年左右就在电视上播出了。它
a very long time. Wasn't it the first show on Channel 4? I think it was the first show on Channel 4. And like it's deliberately very, like they haven't moved with the times at all, like it's deliberately really old fashioned and it's kind of like an institution on British TV. But anyway, the goal of Countdown, they have two, they have letters rounds and numbers rounds and letters rounds you have nine letters. Oh! You select nine letters, vowels and consonants and you have to make the longest word you can. So two contestants, each one tries to get the longest word. And numbers rounds,
已经很长时间了。它不是第四频道的第一档节目吗？我想它是第四频道的第一档节目。而且它故意非常，就像他们根本没有与时俱进，它故意非常老派，在英国电视上就像一个机构。但总之，《Countdown》的目标是，他们有两个，他们有字母轮和数字轮，字母轮你有九个字母。哦！你选择九个字母，元音和辅音，你必须组成你能组成的最长的单词。所以两个参赛者，每个人都试图得到最长的单词。而数字轮，
you pick six numbers and you're given a three-digit target, and you have to use the usual four-hour binary operations to reach that target. So I thought this would be right up your street. And I thought it would actually make quite a fun thing to do on the podcast. But December's a busy time. This sounds amazing.
你挑选六个数字，给你一个三位数的数字目标，你必须使用通常的四种二元运算来达到那个目标。所以我认为这正合你的胃口。而且我认为这实际上会成为播客中一件非常有趣的事情。但十二月是个忙碌的时候。这听起来太棒了。
And I just finished cutting in the inception, the audio from the inception movie when they were dream building, which people may or may not have gotten the reference. I am definitely going to find the clip. I don't think it's countdown because this was like a comedy show and I'm not gonna remember the comedian's name.
我刚刚剪辑了《盗梦空间》的开头，当他们在构建梦境时的音频，人们可能听出来了，也可能没听出来。我一定要找到那个片段。我不认为它是《Countdown》，因为这是一个喜剧节目，我记不住那个喜剧演员的名字。
His name's is I think Richard Yeah, yeah, I think is it is it from the IT crowd where he's on countdown I'm not sure but it's it's this old grumpy lady who's like hosting this quiz show I think and And you have to like unscramble the word which sounds exactly like it is and then he Supposedly finishes it in like three seconds flat but like you can clearly tell that these nine letters are not forming a whole word and And so then he just starts humming a little jingle like and he's making fun of this lady being like I can't remember if it's like don't be grumpy or whatever And then she's telling him to be quiet and it is it one of the funniest clips I've seen
他的名字是，我想是 Richard。是的，是的，我想是……它是来自《IT狂人》吗？他在《Countdown》里。我不确定，但这是一个脾气暴躁的老太太在主持这个问答节目，我想，你必须解开那个单词，听起来完全一样，然后他据称在三秒内就完成了，但你可以清楚地看出这九个字母并没有组成一个完整的单词，然后他就开始哼唱一个小曲子，他在取笑这个老太太，说“我记不清是不是像‘别那么暴躁’之类的”，然后她让他安静，这是我见过的最有趣的片段之一。
Yeah, anyways, I'm not sure if this sounds familiar at all I will find it once we're done recording and I'll send it to you in advance. So you guys Hello All your countdown Don't interrupt me. Tell Rachel your letters. What's happening Rach, a couple of Bs, Qs, N, J. Just pick a letter. Bit serious on this show, innit? I'll tell you what, put whatever you want up there. Alright, ok, we've got... Help yourself, like a pick-a-mix. C, L, L, U, D, B, R, A and T.
是的，总之，我不确定这听起来是否耳熟。一旦录制完成，我会找到它并提前发给你。所以你们……你好，欧拉的《Countdown》。别打断我。告诉 Rachel 你的字母。怎么了 Rach，几个 B，Q，N，J。随便选一个字母。这节目挺严肃的，是吧？我告诉你，把你想放的都放上去。好吧，好的，我们有……随便拿，像混合糖果一样。C，L，L，U，D，B，R，A 和 T。
Okay. Start the clock. Start the clock. Mr. Gaser, put the cares in the freezer. Anne Robinson. Anne Robinson, have a breather. Okay, okay. Okay!
好的。开始计时。开始计时。Gaser 先生，把烦恼放进冰箱里。Anne Robinson。Anne Robinson，喘口气。好的，好的。好的！
We don't do that. Well, can't you do that? No. Robison and Robison ever breeze up okay, okay? Okay, we don't do that Shirley and Lisa gonna have a pizza. Oi oi! Okay. Fantastic, okay. Boom, I've got all the letters, Susie.
我们不那样做。嗯，你不能那样做吗？不。Robison 和 Robison 喘口气，好的，好的？好的，我们不那样做，Shirley 和 Lisa 要去吃披萨。嘿嘿！好的。太棒了，好的。砰，我拿到了所有的字母，Susie。
Blood clot. Fantastic, so I win, eh? That's not a word. That's a word? You're a bit moody, aren't you? Come on, give us a smile. That's not a word. ****
血块（Blood clot）。太棒了，所以我赢了，嗯？那不是一个单词。那是一个单词？你有点喜怒无常，不是吗？来吧，给我们一个微笑。那不是一个单词。****
And you are the weakest link goodbye Don't need to wait Okay, but I mean some of the I think my favorite comedian right now. What's his name? Oh, no He's a very skinny nerdy James a castor. Yes. He is hilarious. Yes He he is great. James A. Castor. His special on Netflix was very funny. Is that the one where he comes out and he starts swearing for the first time?
你是最弱的一环，再见。不需要等待。好的，但我的意思是，我想我目前最喜欢的喜剧演员。他叫什么名字？哦，不。他是一个非常瘦、书呆子气的 James Acaster。是的。他太搞笑了。是的。他很棒。James Acaster。他在 Netflix 上的特辑非常有趣。那是他出来并第一次开始说脏话的那一个吗？
Oh my God, because he's this very straight-laced guy and all his comedy stand-ups or whatever are very kind of, you know, yeah, straight-laced, doesn't swear and then in this one, he comes out and just starts cursing and he's like, I found out all my viewers and fans are old moms and young Harry Potter readers and he's like, I'm done with this, you know? And it is... Right, let's start with the headlines. I swear now. Started swearing in my stand-up comedy. 10 years in the game I've been a pretty clean comedian
哦，天哪，因为他是一个非常循规蹈矩的人，他所有的喜剧脱口秀之类的都非常，你知道，是的，循规蹈矩，不说脏话，然后在这一场里，他出来就开始骂人，他说，“我发现我所有的观众和粉丝都是老妈妈和年轻的哈利波特读者，”他说，“我受够了这个，你知道吗？”而且它是……好了，让我们从头条新闻开始。我现在发誓。开始在我的脱口秀喜剧中说脏话。入行 10 年，我一直是一个相当干净的喜剧演员，
and I f'ing Jeff that much and as a result I've attracted a demographic who to be frank I hate. It's a bunch of old people and Christians every goddamn show. I'm sick of it. Gotta ditch these crizzos ASAP. Seriously man, after every single gig, something from mum comes up to me. Oh, me and my daughter love that! Well I may as well quit now then. If you and your daughter are enjoying it on the same level, the fuck am I doing? Yeah, he's hilarious. I think he's my favorite comedian right now. Anyway, so I do find the UK humor and a lot of that, a lot of it's, I don't want to say classier, but just more intelligent than some of the stuff going on in North America. You should read, I read his book, it's called James A. Castor's Classic Scrapes.
我没怎么骂人，结果我吸引了一个坦白说我讨厌的人群。每一场演出都是一群老人和基督徒。我受够了。得尽快甩掉这些家伙。说真的，伙计，每一场演出后，都有妈妈走过来找我。“哦，我和我女儿都喜欢那个！”好吧，那我不如现在就辞职。如果你和你女儿在同一个层面上享受它，我他妈在干什么？是的，他太搞笑了。我想他是我目前最喜欢的喜剧演员。总之，我确实觉得英国幽默，很多，很多，我不想说更高级，但只是比北美发生的一些事情更聪明。你应该读读，我读过他的书，叫《James Acaster 的经典刮擦》。
And is that good? It's worth a read? It's worth it. If you like James A. Castor, you will laugh out loud when you read that book. Any other any other while we're off topic TV show recommendations, book recommendations, movie recommendations? I've been watching the old midway through the second season of Severance if you haven't seen that. Oh yes yes yes.
那本书好吗？值得一读吗？值得。如果你喜欢 James Acaster，读那本书时你会大声笑出来。还有其他，在我们跑题的时候，电视节目推荐、书籍推荐、电影推荐吗？我一直在看《人生切割术》第二季的中段，如果你还没看过的话。哦，是的，是的，是的。
On Apple TV. I'm up to date as well. Yeah it is, you know, I just think it's some of the best TV that's around at the moment. Very very weird but, great program. Sorry, you were gonna say. I was gonna say, I made some movie recommendations to you, Connor, a while back, because you had said that you and Shima
在 Apple TV 上。我也跟上了。是的，你知道，我只是认为它是目前最好的电视节目之一。非常非常奇怪，但，很棒的节目。抱歉，你刚才要说什么。我本来想说，我很久以前给你做过一些电影推荐，Connor，因为你说过你和 Shima
were going through the AFI Top 100. I will say, here, I'll pull it up right now, if I can find it. We did watch Chiots of fun Do you have a spreadsheet of these? Not only do I have a spreadsheet I have a spreadsheet that is Conditionally formatted because I let I gave it access to my sister and her partner one of my sisters and her partner because they're big movie buffs and we put our after
我们正在过AFI百大电影榜单。我得说，我现在就把它调出来，如果我能找到的话。我们确实看了《烈火战车》。你有这些电影的电子表格吗？我不仅有电子表格，而且还是带有条件格式的电子表格，因为我把它分享给了我妹妹和她的伴侣，因为他们是超级影迷，我们把我们的...
She might I watch it we each rate it and Then based on whether there's a rating there because some of us, you know before we met each other had seen it and others So there's you know, both have seen it one of us has seen it The other has seen it and then there's a very fancy, you know rating Chariots of Fire was on the recommendation list. Mm-hmm We were not a big fan of Chariots of Fire as a running movie. I can't remember. Well, it's not a running movie. It's a movie that contains runners, but...
她可能看了，我们每个人都给它打分，然后根据是否有人打过分——因为我们有些人，你知道，在认识彼此之前就看过它，而其他人没看过——所以你知道，要么两人都看过，要么其中一人看过，另一人没看过，然后还有一个非常高级的评分。当时《烈火战车》在推荐名单上。嗯。我们不太喜欢《烈火战车》作为一部跑步电影。我不记得了。好吧，它不是一部跑步电影。它是一部包含跑步者的电影，但是……
Eh, it's a movie about running. I suppose. You could look at it that way. I can't remember why, because we watched it a few months ago. Maybe it was just, you know, we weren't born in the right decade. Maybe. What was, because you said it was one of your favorites of all time oh absolutely absolutely top five no doubt about it I can watch it any weekend oh yeah no I
呃，我想它是一部关于跑步的电影。你可以这么看。我不记得为什么了，因为我们几个月前才看的。也许只是，你知道，我们出生的年代不对。也许吧。那是因为你说它是你最喜欢的电影之一，哦，绝对是，绝对是前五名，毫无疑问。我任何周末都可以看它，哦，是的，不，我
think I did tell you uh oh no I didn't I didn't give the remove the review you had just mentioned it yeah you said number one chariots of fire the story of two athletes competing in 1924. Brief encounter, the UK's equivalent of Casablanca. Yeah, I have not seen that one yet. Well, so again, brief encounter and Casablanca, you need to see both because they are referenced so, so much in other media.
想我确实告诉过你，哦不，我没有，我没有给出那个评价，你刚才提到了它，是的，你说第一名是《烈火战车》，讲述了1924年两名运动员竞争的故事。《相见恨晚》，英国版的《卡萨布兰卡》。是的，我还没看过那部。好吧，所以再说一次，《相见恨晚》和《卡萨布兰卡》，你都需要看，因为它们在其他媒体中被引用得太多太多了。
Like, I guess it's sort of waning these days, but there was a time when you can't reasonably digest pop culture without running into references to both of these movies or respectively sort of US and UK. And it's still somewhat the case. I think I'm terrible just when it comes to pop culture. In general, I don't do great at trivia, like pub quizzes and stuff, unless if it's like a math or science category.
就像，我想现在这种趋势正在减弱，但曾经有一段时间，如果你不接触这两部电影的引用，就无法合理地消化流行文化，或者说分别是美国和英国的文化。现在情况依然如此。我觉得自己在流行文化方面太糟糕了。总的来说，我不擅长琐事问答，比如酒吧测验之类的，除非是数学或科学类别的。
And for instance, I was just telling Shima this yesterday is that we watched the, or me and my buddies watched the Super Bowl a week ago and Kendrick Lamar performed at the halftime show, I thought it was okay. But I like to go and watch these like breakdowns of like everything you missed and like what it meant. I did not pick up on a single like cultural political reference in that half. Right. Like apparently it was just littered with them and I didn't I didn't understand any of it. So like when it comes to understanding like the cultural significance of like, you know, oh, this is a reference to that or this is a reference or like this had this.
例如，我昨天刚告诉Shima，我和我的伙伴们一周前看了超级碗，肯德里克·拉马尔在中场秀表演，我觉得还行。但我喜欢去看那些关于你错过的所有细节以及它意味着什么的解析。我完全没有领会到那场表演中任何一个文化或政治隐喻。对吧。显然它里面充满了这些隐喻，但我一点也没看懂。所以当涉及到理解文化意义时，比如，哦，这是对那个的引用，或者这是对那个的引用，或者这有这个。
I'm like the most ignorant. I'm just watching it like at surface level being like, oh, does this song sound good? It's like, yeah, this is pretty catchy. Did anybody do a flip? I'm just yeah, I think maybe that's the problem though is I haven't seen enough of these. My brain just doesn't work that way. I'm not able to stitch things together. Yeah, one of my weakest It's probably what makes me bad at cryptics as well, too It comes up less but there was there was an episode of house which referenced Casablanca I've seen all of house never well, it was years ago though. So I'm not gonna remember if I remember
我简直是最无知的。我只是在表面上看着它，心想，哦，这首歌听起来不错？就像，是的，这挺朗朗上口的。有人翻跟头了吗？我只是，是的，我想也许这就是问题所在，我看得不够多。我的大脑就是不那样运作。我无法把事情串联起来。是的，这是我最弱的地方之一。这可能也是我不擅长填字游戏的原因。这种情况出现得较少，但有一集《豪斯医生》引用了《卡萨布兰卡》。我看过所有的《豪斯医生》，从来没有，不过那是几年前的事了。所以我记不住了，如果我记得的话
There was an episode of house where there was like a 17 year old girl who was coming on to him. She ended up having something wrong in her brain that he diagnosed the end, but the end scene of that he came into the office to talk to her and he was basically recreating Humphrey Bogart's speech from the end of Casablanca. If you're not with someone your age, you'll regret it. Maybe not today, maybe not tomorrow, but soon and for the rest of your life. Right. Which to anyone who had seen Casablanca was a great reference.
有一集《豪斯医生》里，有个17岁的女孩在勾引他。她最终大脑出了问题，被他诊断出来了，但那一集的结尾，他走进办公室和她谈话，他基本上是在重现《卡萨布兰卡》结尾亨弗莱·鲍嘉的台词。如果你不和同龄人在一起，你会后悔的。也许不是今天，也许不是明天，但很快，而且会伴随你的余生。对吧。这对任何看过《卡萨布兰卡》的人来说都是一个很棒的引用。
And if you hadn't seen it, it would just totally pass you by. I was one of the people that had passed by for sure. The Simpsons does that with so many things. Right. You can watch an episode of the Simpsons as a kid, right? And then years later, you'll watch a movie and you're like, oh, that's what they were referring to. It's like, yeah, now I get it.
如果你没看过，它就会完全被你忽略。我肯定就是那些忽略了它的人之一。《辛普森一家》在很多事情上都这样做。对吧。你小时候可以看一集《辛普森一家》，对吧？然后多年后，你看了一部电影，你会想，哦，原来他们指的是那个。就像，是的，现在我明白了。
I was just going to say you didn't like Characters of Fire. You may or may not like my other top, my top three movies. Characters of Fire, The Sting, it's a great, it's a great American movie. Shawshank Redemption. That's one that everyone likes. Oh, I love Shawshank. I love Shawshank.
我刚才正想说你不喜欢《烈火战车》。你可能喜欢也可能不喜欢我另外的前三名电影。《烈火战车》、《骗中骗》，这是一部很棒的美国电影。《肖申克的救赎》。那是每个人都喜欢的电影。哦，我爱《肖申克》。我爱《肖申克》。
Yeah, yeah. That's a recognized classic, I think. Yeah. I was wondering if the third one was going to have like an incredible soundtrack as well, like an iconic soundtrack, because the first two. Yes. Oh yeah. The music is such an important part of both of those films.
是的，是的。我认为那是一部公认的经典。是的。我当时在想第三部是否也会有令人难以置信的配乐，就像标志性的配乐一样，因为前两部。是的。哦，是的。音乐是这两部电影中非常重要的一部分。
I mean, I would argue it's the same for Shawashank like I can I can like hum in my head I won't do it on the podcast But like that final scene in case someone hasn't seen shashank I won't ruin anything, but there's a final epic scene where one of the main characters kind of does something significant will say and like That scene when it's raining I can like, the soundtrack for that is just, yeah, fantastic, fantastic. Love Shawshank.
我的意思是，我认为《肖申克的救赎》也是如此，我可以，我可以在脑海里哼出来，我不会在播客里哼的，但就像最后那一幕，以防有人没看过《肖申克》，我不会剧透任何东西，但有一个史诗般的结局，其中一个主角做了一些重要的事情，我们这么说吧，那一幕在下雨的时候，我可以，那段配乐简直是，是的，太棒了，太棒了。爱《肖申克》。
And I love watching Shawshank with people that haven't seen Shawshank. I've probably seen it like six times because like anytime I find out that someone hasn't seen Shawshank, I'm just like, well, we got to watch Shawshank. It's like one of the most enjoyable movies to watch With people that haven't seen it and that it haven't haven't like don't know the plot of it Obviously anyways, alright. Well tie a bow. I'll let for the listener. I will watch Ben's other favorites and we will let you know There's hope though because I do like Shawshank Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions.
而且我喜欢和没看过《肖申克》的人一起看《肖申克》。我可能已经看过六次了，因为每当我发现有人没看过《肖申克》，我就会说，好吧，我们得看《肖申克》。这是和没看过的人一起看最令人愉快的电影之一，而且他们不知道剧情。显然，无论如何，好吧。打个结。对于听众，我会看本的其他最爱，我们会让你知道。不过还是有希望的，因为我确实喜欢《肖申克》。请务必查看播客应用或adspthepodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反支撑者。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。